في ذروه الخوف والهروب الجماعي في الازمات
والكوارث الطبيعيه منها والتي من صنع
البشر لابد من اثر انساني في الخراب يمد
يد العون وينقذ ما يمكن انقاذه
بعد كارثه الزلزال الذي ضرب الشمال السوري
المقسم اصلا لمناطق تحت سيطره قوى مختلفه
وفي ظل صعوبه وصول المساعدات الطارئه لم
يبقى امل للعالقين تحت الانقاض سوى منظمه
القوه البيضاء والتي لم توقف عملياتها منذ
ايام
الدفاع المدني السوري الذي عرف بخوته
البيض طيله فتره الحرب السوريه على مدار
اكثر من عقد هو القوه الوحيده في الميدان
حاليا تحديدا في مناطق سيطره فصائل
المعارضه في ادلب وشمال حلب نقص الاعانات
والمعدات يعرقل جهود فرقهم ما يؤدي الى
الاعتماد الكلي على الوسائل المتاحه
والبحث اليدوي
[تصفيق]
لا تنحصر مهماتهم بالبحث عن الجثث
والناجين بل تجاوز ذلك الى الاسعاف والبحث
عن المفقودين وذويهم ولم يشمل المنكوبين
والتامين الحاجات الاساسيه من غذاء ودواء
وملجا بل والتوفيق ايضا
[تصفيق]
قصص عديده خلال ايام قصيره وثقتها الخوذ
البيض عبر صفحات وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
ونداءات للمساعده والاعلان عن الناجين
والبحث عن ذويهم
على مر سنوات الحرب السوريه كانت مناطق
النكبات والكوارث والقصف مشاهد الشبه
يوميه يتمسك فيها السكان باقل شعاع امل
للنجاه لتمارس الخوض البيض ذلك الدور اذا
عمر العربيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]